[Musica]
la prima volta che mi hanno parlato del
teatro ho pensato a ted di how i met
your mother ma sono parlando vogliate i
ragazzi ho capito che non era veramente
così
e questo mi fa pensare se fossi nata in
una città diversa low price ha preso il
succo del tema ombre scelto per questa
esposizione è quello di cercare di
capire quanto ciò che ti circonda ci
circonda può influenzare il nostro modo
di pensare e di vivere
innanzitutto io ringrazio il ted e
l'organizzazione del test di colle val
d'elsa per aver pensato a me e spero di
portarvi nella visione del mondo
attraverso quelle in sono le mie
esperienze personali
quella che vi voglio proporre oggi è una
situazione che ho vissuto strettamente
sulla mia pelle perché per chi non mi
conosce mi chiamo irene sono un atleta
professionista pratico atletica leggera
da ormai 13 anni e sono in nazionale dal
mi sono sempre allenata con le di valdez
e solo con l'atletica posso dire di aver
viaggiato in molte parti del mondo anche
se ahimè spesso vedendo solo gli hotel e
le piste di atletica ma oggi toglieremo
un po sul ruolo della grande della
piccola città nel percorso che io ho
avuto da sportiva
quello che mi domando è ma una città
diversa
avrebbe cambiato il mio stile di vita e
quello che sono oggi probabilmente in
una città più grande avrei avuto più
vantaggi come mezzi per raggiungere gli
impianti sportivi più impianti sportivi
e strutture a disposizione più compagni
di allenamento del mio stesso livello
con cui confrontarmi invece dei miei
cinque compagni di scuola delle medie e
giustamente arrivati a un certo punto
della loro vita si sono dedicati altro
e se invece fosse accaduto l'opposto
perché in una grande città hai più
possibilità e se l'atletica non fosse
rientrata tra queste non avrei mai
saputo quello per cui sono portata ma
sono convinta che una persona possa
essere tante cose insieme ma pensando
alle mie possibilità future
mi domando spesso se una città diversa
avrebbe cambiato il mio percorso ma
tornando al caso della piccola città
sicuramente non sa tutto ma sono
convinta che sia la società spesso
stessa il modo di pensare che porta a
rendere un posto aperto chiuso vagliando
per noi una serie di possibilità immenso
ma come fanno le persone che incontriamo
durante la nostra strada
tornando al mio caso da sportiva sono
molto felice di dirvi che nella piccola
città dove vivo c'è un'enorme quantità
di sport negli anni oltre al calcio si
sono appropriate della città molti altri
sport minori e da questo punto di vista
ogni grande città ogni piccola città può
diventare una metropoli dello sport e a
questo punto vi chiedo secondo voi a chi
dareste un like alla grande alla piccola
città da che punto di vista vorreste
parlarle io sinceramente avrei dato un
like sia alla grande città che alla
piccola città perché alla fine per pro e
contro si equilibrano ma andando avanti
vi pongo un'altra questione il fatto di
avere tutta questa possibilità ma un
bacino di raccolta minore rispetto a una
grande città che cosa porta perché le
società per sopravvivere hanno bisogno
gli iscritti e se i bambini che si
avvicinano allo sport hanno così tanta
scelta tra società come faccio io
società ad attirarli verso di me
spesso ci troviamo di fronte a delle
realtà in cui le società non riescano a
sopravvivere per mancanza proprio di
materia prima che sono gli sportivi e
probabilmente alcuni degli sport di
squadra presenti in un territorio hanno
delle difficoltà perché diciamocelo
servirebbero tra virgolette anche degli
sponsor o perché non riescano ad essere
a raggiungere dei livelli alti per
proprio per mancanza di elementi che
compongono una squadra ma quanto sarebbe
bello se in un piccolo paese come il
nostro una squadra riuscisse negli anni
a costruire la propria i propri elementi
e crescerli arrivare ad un certo punto è
un grande obiettivo un grande risultato
senza avere elementi esterni e vorrei
farvi un'altra domanda una questione che
mi domando sia una bambina vuole fare
atletica leggera dove deve andare in un
impianto sportivo in una pista
possibilmente di 400 metri ma sapete
quante piste di 400 metri esistono in
italia soprattutto omologate non lo so
non ho trovato il risultato ma non tante
però sicuro perché ne ho girate
parecchie e oggi ragazzi se a noi hanno
spesso cambiano idea velocemente e certe
volte in una piccola città fanno fatina
se smettono uno sport di iniziarne un
altro e questo mi fa pensare ma in una
grande città nella città più grande
succede lo stesso probabilmente sotto
gli occhi degli allenatori in questo
caso c'è un ricambio più veloce di
atleti e una maggiore scelta per le
società che andranno a comporre delle
squadre e in questo caso
problema qual è una grande città
probabilmente si combatte più contro
società di uno stesso sport per i
tesseramenti ma non guardiamola solo in
negativo perché può diventare in
equazioni e più società ci sono e meno
bambini iscritti è uguale alla società
una spinta migliorare la propria spinta
trattiva per attirare appunto gli atleti
verso la propria società
mentre nella piccola città questo non
succede perché spesso non ci sono troppe
società per uno stesso sport quindi il
problema non si pone
e io penso che sia proprio il luogo in
cui una persona vive che a volte
influenza le nostre scelte perché se un
ragazzo vuole fare badminton in una
città che non ha il badminton questo non
lo farà mai e da questo punto di vista
vi chiedo voi a chi dareste awlaki ha
più pro e più contro la grande città o
la piccola città e io l'ho data la
grande città perché più grande e più
possibilità ai ma passando a un'altra
problematica
esiste anche la problematica degli
spostamenti
perché se un ragazzo abita fuori città
in campagna come è arrivato un impianto
sportivo
capita spesso e ho conosciuto persone
che lo hanno fatto che la famiglia si
trasferisce da una piccola città una
grande città per far crescere
sportivamente il figlio aprirli tante
strade ma lo farebbero frutti tutti i
genitori lo farebbero tutti
cambierebbero vita
credo che oltre alla volontà in un caso
del genere subentrino anche dei fattori
esterni non valutabili dato che ogni
situazione è soggettiva ma esistono
anche casi in cui il ragazzo non riesce
a fare sport perché il genitore o chi
per lui non ha la possibilità ho i mezzi
per portarlo ma nessuna di queste
situazioni è sbagliato negativa
semplicemente esistono delle priorità di
vita e probabilmente in una grande città
con più compagni di allenamento ai un
aiuto in più per organizzati per
l'allenamento ma d'altro canto nella
piccola città probabilmente hai tutti
gli impianti sportivi più vicino quindi
arrivi meglio anche a piedi da una parte
all'altra
io penso che negli ultimi anni se c'è la
volontà di fare sport e soprattutto dopo
il periodo che abbiamo passato anche se
l'impianto sportivo a 50 chilometri di
distanza una persona vuole star bene con
se stessa non si pone molto il problema
e quindi vi chiedo a chi dareste un like
io l'ho da fa tutti e due perché bene o
nel male nella grande e la piccola città
hanno dei pregi e dei difetti in questo
senso ma iniziato a tenere il conto
perché mi interrogo su quanti laiche
abbiamo dato ma passando appunto 4 è una
questione che su cui ho riflettuto per
quanto riguarda la mia storia perché la
questione dell'essere famosi se in un
piccolo paese o città tutti nasce e
cresce un campione ma come può essere un
pittore un
politico un artista tutti si rivolgono
di lui e lo riconoscono per strada e ciò
mi fa riflettere sulla società che ci
circonda perché è grazie alla piccola
realtà in cui noi viviamo che vengano
tessuti i nostri rapporti interpersonali
perché se in un piccolo paese tutti
conoscono tutti risulta anche normale
riconoscere salutare per strada il
campione dato che magari lo hai visto
crescere fin da quando era piccolino ma
sono convinta che se fosse il contrario
che il campione nascesse in una grande
città come può essere roma non avrebbe
lo stesso risalto e se tra dieci anni
probabilmente tutti si ricorderanno
della velocista del paesino è andata
alle olimpiadi come nel mio caso a roma
ne sarà passata di acqua di campioni
sotto pontino e quindi a questo punto il
like io lo darei alla piccola città
perché permette all'atleta di essere più
in vista di essere più riconosciuto ma
passiamo all'ultimo punto che una
missione molto spinosa cioè i genitori
e questo punto che abbiamo appena
affrontato mi lascia aperta un'altra
stato il pensiero ma che siano i nostri
genitori a influenzare le nostre scelte
ve lo siete mai chiesto sicuramente lo
fanno se in modo conscio inconscio credo
che dipenda da caso a caso
ma credo anche fortemente in questo caso
non dipenda dal contesto in cui noi
viviamo perché tutti i genitori in un
modo o nell'altro
indirizzano la recita del figlio ma
tornando al caso specifico della piccola
città probabilmente hanno maggiori
conoscenze e spesso vanno sul sicuro per
intenderci mia mamma è amica della mia
attuale allenatrice e
d'altra parte nella grande città è
impossibile conoscere tutti ai meno
sicurezze però più possibilità e anche
se fosse genitori quasi sempre ti
consiglia su cosa provare su dove andare
quindi indipendentemente da dove si
nasce si cresce il passato del genitore
influenzerà più o meno il figlio quindi
mi raccomando genitori influenza teli
bene ea questo punto l'ultimo like io lo
darei a tutti e due perché grande o
piccola città indipendentemente da dove
si nasce si cresce
i genitori e influenzerà in qualche modo
il figlio ma avete tenuto il conto
perché adesso ci avviamo verso la
conclusione e
concludendo il luogo comune che nella
piccola nella grande città si viva
meglio pezzo non trova molto fondamento
perché tutto si basa sulle singole
esperienze personali e degli individui
se una persona si sente stretta nella
vita che sta conducendo probabilmente
non è la città il problema malavita che
porta avanti non raggiunge gli obiettivi
che una persona si è data quindi la
piccola città sicuramente ha dei limiti
ma credo che in una società sempre più
frenetica aggressiva nelle richieste ci
voglia un po più di calma un po più di
senso di pace il ritmo più accessibile
personalmente io preferisco stare
all'aria aperta godermi il vento sulla
faccia e stare in un posto più sano e
poco caotico
sicuramente l'ambiente in cui viviamo
influenza il nostro modo di vivere ma a
questo punto è giusto giudicare vuole
male peggio perché se avete tenuto il
conto abbiamo una parità 4 light per la
mia città 4 like per la piccola città
abbiamo una parità di pro e contro una
parità di luci e ombre che è proprio il
tema di oggi ogni individuo porta dentro
di sé la propria esperienza è quello che
ci vuole per vivere bene è un po di pace
interiore non farsi influenzare a questo
punto dall ambiente ti circonda ma
influenzarlo positivamente a nostra
volta io sono riuscita a raggiungere
molti dei miei obiettivi rimanendo
fedele a quello che per me è il più bel
posto del mondo e certo non ha una pista
da bowling a un centro commerciale ma
forse è proprio questo il bello perché
non avere tutto a portata di mano ti
obbliga a uscire da tre schemi mentali e
crescere grazie per l'attenzione
[Musica]